we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p let's take a listen to this
voicemail that came in and it relates to
something we talked about today actually
hi david i keep hearing people throw
around that if like if Trump were to be
impeach that pence would be even worse
what are they talking about and what do
you think yeah well what they're talking
about is that Mike Pence Trump is nuts
and doesn't really know anything but he
sort of accidentally comes across some
more moderate views even if it's as a
result of just sheer under
misunderstanding of the issues Mike
Pence is a committed right religious
right-wing ideologue and in many ways as
Pat alluded to earlier he might be able
to coalesce Republican support around
the administration in a way that Trump
hasn't exactly been able to do yet so I
completely agree with the idea that
pence is president would likely be more
dangerous than Trump I think there's an
exception though where pence will be
better on foreign policy because maybe
this is hyperbolic but if we're going to
nuclear war I think that would be of
much they'll be much more likely to
happen on the Trump and pence you're
right Trump seeming to not get why it
would be so bad to use nuke during the
lead-up to the election is something
that I had get the sense Pence has a
good grasp on which is like you don't
really want to use nukes nukes are
they're mostly for sort of deterrent
purposes and it's not the type of thing
where he would say why can't we nuke
Europe why would that be so bad as
Donald Trump reportedly didn't
understand so yes when that aside I do
believe that pence would be other than
the wholesale destruction of the planet
through our weapons I think pens would
be more dangerous than Donald Trump on
the bonus show today Rosie O'Donnell
wants to play Steve Bannon on Saturday
Night Live I think that would probably
anger President Donald we're going to
debunk some poverty myths and we also
have a very interesting story about an
Alaska Airlines flight attendant who
saved a human trafficking victim very
interesting story that we'll discuss on
the bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code I voted 17 to
sign up and get instant access to the
bonus show